[音楽]
[拍手]
今日はですねお前大丈夫かふらふらし
ちゃった
爽健のお家で
サイレント鬼ごっこというものやってみ
たいと思います畑で何回かやったのでそれ
を今回この3億円のお家でやってみようと
いう企画でございますもう結構畑の皆も
その辺のお家に来てかなり月日が経ってる
のでもう分かるんですなんとなく場所
もちろんばっちりですか
今回こちらのイケメンに集まっていただき
ましたみんなイケメンですね
サイレント2個
ルールは
鬼がこの赤い服着た人たち5人です皆さん
は目隠しをして制限時間内に青い服を着た
人を見つけてください
色わかんないですとりあえず俺を見つけて
ください俺を見つけてタッチしたらもう
勝ちです
[音楽]
3億円のおうちかなり広いんですけど人数
が結構いるので
宣言が30分でやります
ルールとしては外禁止ブランドとか外
っぽいところももうダメ室内のみになり
ますあと地下の禁止さーてのお家を知って
いる人間僕以外にもう1人スペシャリスト
がいますどうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
動かしますね
僕はこの中で一番詳しいんじゃないかなと
管理人ですからね
僕の家じゃないかなってくらいに思ってる
んで違います大地君と俺が今回逃げます
もうこの家を知り尽くせれば
スペシャリスト2人があればなんとか逃げ
切れるんじゃないかということで松本さん
自身はありますかまぁ大地君臭いんでね
匂いでわかると思います
サイレントなのでいかに物事を聞いて
見つけられるかどうか勝負になってくると
思いますそれではサイレントやっていく
ぞー
[拍手]
皆さん来てくださいよしじゃあちょっと
どこまでがOKどこまでがダメかしっかり
で確認していきましょうじゃあ鬼はここら
辺からスタートしてここもありねここも
でこっから外をなしここなしです
[音楽]
よねさすがにここ
ら辺はありだけどリスクがあるからねあー
確かにね
ここから先はここから外が若干外っぽいの
で
ここなしここで内側にします
ここもガレージなのでなしストクラブなし
で
ここちょっと物事とか出して危ないので
なしです1階はこの部屋だけなしです上
行きましょう
[音楽]
ついでに2回です2回もねここもなしかな
ここからが外判定なのでここよりこっち側
この中です
マジで室内だけってことでそこから出るの
も無しねここからも外なのでここ内側また
全部アジ
まぁ3回は大丈夫か4回
4回も基本的に外に行ける場所がここしか
ないのでこのベランダみたいなところは
禁止もう外っぽいとこは全部大きいです
弟の部屋があるんですけどもここはかなり
弟のプライベートのものたくさんあります
さすがにちょっと映せないんですけどここ
ありです
こんな感じでどうでしょうもう完璧ですか
ワンちゃん何も見つからない可能性あり
ますけど大丈夫ですか
畑のみんなもだけど
澤部がマジでほぼ俺の今速記みたいな
ムーブしてるからかなりいい匂い悔しいの
で割とキーパーソンな気がするじゃあ5分
後スタートで
なんとかくれば見つけますでは
[音楽]
さあどうするこれ
大地君は何なら俺より詳しいと思うから
ちょっと1回2回目頑張って
2階今回ね
逃げれる空間を作るなるほどね俺ちょっと
震えちゃうから
頑張ってください
ちょっとなめてるんで見てますね近くで
[音楽]
いけいけ
こちら
は
ね
[音楽]
俺は
上行きます
ちょ待ってよ
[音楽]
いるんだろう
君もいるのかなここに
ね
はいやばい
やばい
相手が
課金を締めるのでこれが
あっちに
救われたくないから
行きます
[音楽]
絶対見つける
ちょっとなんか投げてみよう
これ4階に行く予定なんでしばらく大丈夫
だと思った三井さんなければ
やばい
[音楽]
怖いよ
ね
絶対こっちだ
[音楽]
いやあるぞこれエレベーターでしょ
いやマジで俺はわかるはじめさんが言う
ところ絶対エレベーターに乗ってるなんか
痛みでエレベーター動かしてみます
[音楽]
あれ来ないな
2回多分いないですよ
音が全くしなかったです
[拍手]
[音楽]
よ
ちょっと見に行ってみるか
[音楽]
僕が何してんの俺今左から
待って冷蔵庫
これどこだ今これこれ
抜けるんだ
絶対抜けてきた
今
[拍手]
3回やるんだよ
入れました
[音楽]
頑張れないですか
あと20分ですあと20分10分で結構
あいつくんどうやって逃げたんだろう
いないね
照明玄関
[音楽]
[拍手]
上手くなかった
皆さんお知らせです
半分経過しました
広いのでここから
1回閉鎖です
234です
ここ寝室
来た
いつも寝てます
2回だけだからね
エレベーターで
上がると
やばいです
[音楽]
ドア
[拍手]
[音楽]
閉められました
多分だけど俺の近くにいるぞ
あ俺の近くにいる俺の近くにいるいるいる
俺ここ
これはまだ俺よ
ほらほらほらほらほらほら
遺体が
勝手に捕まえられるこれね
いやいるな
いやこの奥の
まずここを
圭介
始めるいや大臣が
でもそこバリケードできてんだよね
キッチン
どうなってる
揺れた
蹴られたぞ今俺だ
おい絶対いるぞー
静かにしているんだよ
気がするんだけど
青色のパーカー
めっちゃすんだよ
[音楽]
4回4回4回今シュートした皆さん
残り10分です
[拍手]
2回閉鎖です
[音楽]
[拍手]
4回のみじゃあラストです
[音楽]
めちゃくちゃ使われにくい捕まりやすいと
思いますその
困難を乗り越えていくのが初めて
4日に今行ってる人は
もう音するけどね多分ここにいいんだよ
なぁここで今見てんだよ
[音楽]
でもここにもう1人いるよ
ほらここに絶対いるだってもう音するもん
えでもほらほら
[音楽]
ここにいる
走れ
[音楽]
早く4回来てよ
俺が外で待機してるOk
お願いしますはい
[音楽]
いるでしょ
これですか
[拍手]
足音的に
正面
椅子が3つあるからだ
この書面
昼は
これいるぞ多分手当てするだけ今
いるいる
[拍手]
よ
もうこの
入って右側のエリアにいります
俺結構進んでるよたける君の部屋側の方俺
もブラザー
[音楽]
キッチンだな
あと3分ですか
[音楽]
かったやついやそこに行ったけどなあれが
絶対この
棚の上上乗ってるよねうんやりかねない
あの人は
多分そう普通に歩いてたら
ぶつかってる
から普通に考えてるほらほらほらこれ
でいいよ
[音楽]
すげえお前まじかえ残り何秒よし
14秒
[音楽]